I think part of the allure of going out
on your own right for for journalists
that I've seen do this
is hey look I got to write the stories
that I want to write right and it's not
to say that they couldn't always do that
but there's definitely editors and kind
of other things at play when you're
writing stories and so that's an
attractive component to it but what you
lose is those editors you lose some of
the support staff use some of the
resources so kind of have you thought
about the pros and cons of those large
organizations right you get some freedom
but you also lose some resources and
just kind of like how do you balance
that in your head and think about it as
you kind of start now yeah so I mean
I've done seven years as a full-time
reporter after starting out freelance
and I feel like if I were to do this
starting out I wouldn't know what I was
doing like I mean I started out you know
doing for was blogging when Forbes would
let lots of people you know go and use
its platform and that was like a good
learning moment for me and it was a way
for me to sort of make mistakes in real
time now like I feel like I have an idea
you know of what I'm doing and I feel
confident that I'll be able to find the
stories that are gonna cut through and
like you know what my newsletter
beforehand I think that watching the
type of stuff that I would write and how
it would resonate with people was like a
good chance for me to sort of give this
a give us a shot experiment a little bit
and see if it could be something more
broadly more broad you know you can't
you can't I feel like everyone could use
an editor like you can't replace the
value an editor brings so while I'm
excited to start assigning myself
stories I am gonna miss that second set
of eyes you know this isn't something
interesting the Ben Smith brought up in
one of his recent columns about you know
people going out and going independent
whether it's celebrities or like you
know you know people with influential
tech followings or like be less
journalists like myself you know it's
like the the services that are the
services that are there for you like
stack may eventually start doing
something like you know once they get
enough people are they gonna have an
editor on call that you can just you
know call to and talk a little bit about
I could see that happening are they
gonna have health care okay that might
be more of a stretch but the editor
thing certainly certainly possible and
you know until that day like you know
when I have something that's pretty
you know controversial or you know I'm
not sure about I'll just cut check it
like I'm lucky to have friends who are
reporters who you know I probably can't
ask them every day but every now and
again I'm sure I can say hey can you
just take a look at this before I hit
the publish button and I don't know if
it's gonna be something that will be
smooth all the time like it will
definitely have hiccups in the way that
working in a established media
corporation you know
didn't you know wouldn't have as many of
and you know my approach to this is to
admit that that's gonna happen to ask my
readers to trust me
to admit when I mess up because I will
and to learn and grow from it yeah I
look you already know this but I'd be
remiss if I didn't tell you the whole
key is the persistence of just doing it
in a very disciplined manner right hey
I'm gonna write every Monday write every
Monday and make the mistakes and stuff
but uh I think I've been writing on sub
stack for two years now actually as of
May and that's probably the most
defendable thing I've done is I just did
it everyday writing and a lot of other
people started out and then stopped at
some point how do you think about this
changing the content you write and what
I mean by that is when you're writing a
story at BuzzFeed it's less your opinion
and it's much more kind of reporting the
facts now you do have that trust of the
reader right they're subscribing to hear
from you you think that that leads to
more opinionated pieces do you want to
write more opinion like to talk a little
bit about how you kind of balance the
opinion component given that now it's
less hey I'm just reading this on
BuzzFeed and maybe I don't know or
and paid attention to who the writer is
now no I'm specifically getting this
because I've chosen to get content from
Alex yeah I mean I think the reporting
will lead the way so people are gonna
hear the reporting first and in my
opinion second but I think that there's
definitely gonna be a more opinion and
the stuff that I write and I'm excited
to do that
I don't think there should be in any
form of journalism well actually maybe
that's debatable but like every venue
you should have if you have an opinion
you should have the ability to write it
otherwise you know we're holding stuff
back from readers and what you know who
does that yeah what type of good does
that do I'm not into it so yeah I think
the readers of this newsletter will hear
what I think for real
there might be surprised like you know
like I talked about narratives like
oftentimes coverage goes and narratives
you know people say what's the big story
and then they'll try to advance you know
and I'm just kind of skeptical of that a
lot of the time like people will not
hear you know after reading a story in
the New York Times and The Wall Street
Journal and a BuzzFeed unfortunate and
in Forbes they won't see my you know
same story they're gonna see a different
perspective from me so it's going to be
there'll be a lot of first-person
there'll be some opinion I mean my book
is like a good example and you know is
day one you'll see the reporting lead
you'll get I feel like a reader can kind
of get lost in the reporting and then
I'll bring it back and to like what I
saw and what I felt and yeah like I
think it'll be it'll be a two-way
conversation it will be me learning from
subscribers them learning from me and
who knows like it might go in different
interesting directions we could get
spiritual we can think about you know
things like meaning which i think is
important to think about when you think
about tech and ultimately we'll just
I'll just let that two-way discussion
Drive